[Music]  Mayor Michael Bloomberg sponsored a law  that will prevent the sale of all sugary  drinks larger than 16 ounces big story  but yesterday just hours before the law  was supposed to go into effect a judge  declared the giant soda ban illegal well  New Yorkers immediately took to the  streets to celebrate it was crazy wake  up everybody  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  why did it end with a woman from the  1940s yelling out a window and what time  is she going to bed if she's to look at  now if it's New York City where were  there only four people and everything  else was empty right I've got a lot of  celebrating a band that hadn't taken  effect yet yeah that's right Andy this  show blows I've been telling you that  for years  [Laughter]  [Applause]